tom vilsack is not the thief he is the
United States Secretary of Agriculture
and he can help us figure out what's
happening secretary we're looking at the
price of beef rising is this just a very
simple consequence of a drought or are
there other market forces at play it
absolutely is a consequence of the draw
okay higher grain prices basically
people shrank their herds we're
beginning to see an uptick on herds and
it we're beginning to see an increase in
export opportunities so so there's no
change in consumption habits in the US
for example not really it's pretty much
flat line if we if we stick with beef
for a second you here today to talk
about trade and particularly beef has
been a sticking point in the Pacific
with Japan and with South Korea if we're
going to move this trade agreement
forward which the president has said is
a priority how do you get past that
basically making the case that a science
based in rules-based system allows for
our beef to go into those markets in
fact we are seeing expanded opportunity
in both Japan and Korea the problem is
not so much in beef it's in dairy its
and poultry it's in rice and some of the
other commodities there but 1800 lines
of debate in negotiation in this trade
agreement so there's a lot of
Agriculture but you can't just make a
science-based case you got to give
something to what's gonna be given well
actually our markets are so open it's
really not so much about what we're
giving it's basically suggesting that we
have an open market and they need to
have a market that is as open as ours
and if that's the case you know we will
always be competitive the days get
longer how do you have American farmers
back what is the initiative right now of
USDA to protect to advance our farming
record exports expansion of local
regional food systems the development of
ecosystem markets and encouraging more
conservation and the Bioeconomy the
ability to tips that does that a jargon
alert I'm waiting let's say what he says
what is the Bioeconomy it's making
everything in the economy from bio-based
materials so you take corn stover and
you can produce chemicals you take
animal waste and you can produce a wide
variety of materials it's an incredible
new explosion of innovation in
agriculture and in manufacturing but do
we really need more farmers aren't we
playing paying plenty of farmers to not
farm no we're paying farmers to make
sure that we always have the food
security that we join in this country we
have the most affordable and most
diverse food supply in the country in
the world and it gives us an opportunity
frankly
for everyone around this table to do
exactly what you're doing today because
you delegated the responsibility of
feeding your families to somebody else
is it is it Brennan is it true that food
here is a third less than Europe is that
as a general statement that's my
experience I have no idea when I was in
Europe I was feeding coasters yourself
it's half we spend around ten percent of
our paychecks support for food in most
developed countries it said 20 to 25
your entourage it came with you today
what are they former linebackers at
Missouri or something sorry to them
they're good folks yeah secretary um you
know we've been talking about trade
within this trans-pacific partnership
but one of the most significant
acquisitions from abroad of our
purchases of American products is the
Chinese acquisition of pork suppliers
are should we be worried at all about
somebody else controlling such a vital
part of our own economy in the way we
feed ourselves not necessarily I mean
the whole idea I really kind of
surprised by these questions because
this is jobs day on the station and
actually trade is about jobs it's 11
million jobs that are supported and one
of the problems with trade in this
country is that we don't do enough
explanation of how it is connected two
jobs and these are jobs that pay better
thirteen to eighteen percent more export
jobs vs non export jobs that's why this
trade agreements so important it's 123
billion dollars additional opportunity